[Music]
for me I think data is life everyday
we're using data but I as a data
scientist I'm using data to quantify
human behavior around the world so our
research as a whole seeks do you
understand whether we can use online
data to better understand human behavior
and our experience in the world we live
in my inspiration for the tracking
process cities dates back to 2013 during
the time of the major process around the
world so I analyzed twenty five million
images taken and upload it to a picture
sharing platform on social media across
two hundred and forty four countries and
continents analyzing almost twenty five
million images could have taken me ten
months to run it on my own machine but
using Azure I was able to run it in less
than a week I'm no longer afraid to add
more data my analysis I feel braver
about my research to explore more data
and scale up my project I'm aiming to
highlight the potential value of online
data especially online images as a new
source of global and cheaply available
measures of human behavior around the
world
you